if you missed any of the interviews this
week from the mercedes-amg man cave
including that Chris Simms interview
yesterday you can get them on the Dan
Patrick show lap mercedes-amg the best
or nothing we bring in Daniel Jeremiah
NFL Network analyst and of course a
former NFL scout he's at the NFL Combine
today let me start with what Chris Simms
had to say yesterday he said a few
things Daniel this is what he had to say
about the best quarterback in the draft
I think the best quarterback in the
draft is Lamar Jackson from Louisville I
mean III really yeah I know you're
looking I didn't think I was gonna be
saying that two three days ago when I
started in on this I didn't I started
watching I went Josh Allen one Baker
Mayfield to then I watch Sam Darnell
they watched Josh Rosen and then I
watched Lamar Jackson and I came away
and I write notes I got my notebook I
could show you everything I write and I
came away and I said the Marg accents
the best quarterback in this draft for
me
he's the only one that has no questions
the only question you have about him is
you know can he take the beating and the
way he plays in the NFL but
decision-making throwing accuracy
accuracy to a degree but I would I would
argue there a little bit I mean he he
doesn't get a ton of easy throws he
throws the ball down the field
aggressively all right Daniel what do
you think of Chris Simms
I think it's it's weird to be put in a
spot Dan because I feel like I've been
defending Lamar Jackson put a different
hat on slow the train down and say well
wait a second no I I don't I don't think
he's the best quarterback in this class
and I think when you look at some
mechanical things when you look at the
accuracy I mean he does have some some
bad misses when you when you watch him
on tape now I think he's a special
athlete he's got a strong arm there's a
lot to work with but I think he's really
really raw and it's gonna take some time
before he's he's ready to get out on the
field so yeah look I didn't yeah I've
been saying he's gonna be a first-round
pick and then all of a sudden Sims blows
that up when he says no he'd be the
number one pick what's the big rumor at
the combine what's the scuttlebutt oh
here's one for you Dan this is again
take it with a grain of salt but
there's a lot of buzz around here saying
okay Cleveland it sounds like
quarterback at number one but then this
one kind of took me for a loop so don't
be surprised with all the pics that they
have if they double up at the
quarterback position in the second round
no well then why not go one in four if
you're gonna do that and just take two
quarterbacks well let's get that started
then you got a big audience here Dan you
got to get it right one of these times
so why not just draft two of these guys
who's the best quarterback who give me
the first quarterback taken yeah well I
think it's the same answer I do think
it's Santorum okay I've been rolling
with him throughout the whole process
and he could do everything you need to
do the kids 20 years old one of the
thing I don't one of the aspects of his
game that doesn't get talked about
enough is that the college game so much
of it Dan is on the perimeter and so
that people go okay this guy didn't turn
the ball over oh yeah you're throwing
bubble screens and tunnel screens and
everything's to the perimeter they don't
ever work in the middle of the field and
make those tight window throws that kind
of those big throws you got to make at
the next level and Donald doesn't have
any fear sometimes it works against him
but he's worked in the middle of the
field he's been able to sort through all
that trash inside so I think the
adjustment will be a little bit easier
for him than for something to do the guy
yeah I'm just trying to figure out how
teams are assessing him because he did
have fumble issues I think last year
people looked at it everybody was
looking at him last year as opposed to
the year before and they're like you
know that this was a great surprise but
I'm also thinking with him he doesn't
throw at the combine is that a red flag
for you as a former scout look you
always personally disappointed but if
I'm gonna be honest first of all tune in
please tune in because it's gonna be
much less CTV there but no to me the
personal workouts the private workouts
with the team would be the most
important in kind of the postseason
evaluation process then I would probably
rank the Pro date number two and then I
would say throw in here at the combine
would be number three so it's not gonna
have a huge impact trying to off the top
my head I don't think walkthrough went
number one staffer didn't throw you all
the way back to paint in Eli I don't
think they threw either so it won't have
a big impact on him but selfishly
I would like to see them grow how
seriously do teams take hand size for
their quarterbacks it depends if it's me
it's like a minimum threshold and it's
just really kinda if you're over nine
inches I don't think it's a big deal
some teams you know prefer if
everything's close in the evaluation
okay you like a guy with a little bit
bigger hand to be able to handle cold
weather and and all that stuff but to me
I think even John Dorsey said it all the
quarterbacks here that are in the mix
you know at the top tier guys they all
met the threshold they needed to meet
what's on tap today at the combine that
we should be aware of well we got
running backs and we've got and you got
offensive linemen and then we've got
running backs going today and their
running backs I was just looking through
my notes on guys I've got top three
round grades on ten different running
backs so as good as last year's group
was I think we've got another group here
today you know say Kwan's establishes
the number one guy but there's a there's
a big-time competition to be number two
between darius guys from LSU Ronald
Jones from SC Sony Michele from Georgia
it's gonna be fun to watch those guys
get out there on the same field run
around it feels like the two best
players in the draft are running back
and an offensive guard and they normally
they normally don't go number one in the
draft right so how do you assess where
Quentin Nelson goes the guard out of
Notre Dame and where say Quan Barkley
goes given the fact of what the running
back means two offenses now as opposed
to 10 years ago yeah look you can you
can go around and talk to people in this
building and you'll get some people that
are strong and their conviction that hey
look at the top ten backs over the last
few years they've been big hits they've
had a big-time impact and you'll talk to
other guys it'll quickly point out that
Jordan Howard's the creme hunts the
cámaras that you can find later so look
it he's so clean say qualms Berkeley is
so clean in every way he's he's gonna go
way up there and I think he's he's gonna
be a great player Ozzie Newsome used to
always say in our draft room guys in the
first round doubles are okay we can't
strikeout hey you're not gonna strike
out with Quentin Nelson you're not going
to strike out with a qualm Barkley can
you if you're the Browns take him number
one
overall I don't think so I mean I think
we've got a list of at the end I think
the Browns have passed on 17 or 18 of
the starting 32 quarterbacks in the NFL
finally find that you like have some
conviction eventually take one what do
you think the Vikings are gonna do at
the quarterbacking position oh I think I
think you played for the Redskins last
year down yeah you think it's signed
sealed delivered that you're getting rid
of but all your other quarterbacks and
you're gonna take Kirk Cousins yeah I
think so I think they're knocking on the
door of being a Super Bowl team and I
think if you can upgrade at that
position you might be able to get over
the hump you know you got a new
offensive coordinator coming in there
it's kind of makes sense to kind of
start fresh at that position and if I
was Kirk Cousins just surveying all the
different options that are out there if
the money's close I'd be going to
Minnesota as a former scout what's the
one thing the most important thing you
take away from the combine and what's
the most worthless part of the combine
the one thing you take away that has the
most impact which you won't see here
will be the medical grades because you
didn't matter how good your great is on
a player if the doctors won't let you
take him you can't take him so that's
that's an impactful thing I always say
on the field work out wise the corners
40s you know look it you got to be able
to run at that position you can get away
with the four six get it wide reciever
it's tough to play corner if you can't
run so that'll be the biggest test here
the overrated I mean Dan if the
quarterback is one of if they want to if
they want to like to bench I mean go
ahead they don't have to but every now
and then we'll get one guy that wants to
show up and get their attention so it's
just why why are you doing this yeah but
say Kwan Barkley did that yesterday and
put on a show no running back I liked my
Rhine backs to be strong and be able to
bench I don't really care if my
quarterback and put up to 25 okay if he
puts it up nine times or 14 times it
really doesn't doesn't affect it's great
for me I I was always taught that it
gets like 90% mental of you know the
combine with you know the interviews and
just everything that kind of goes into
it the
the preparation it's 10% of just your
performance out there is that a fair
ratio of the combine yeah they get up so
early in the morning and they're doing
or they're doing their weigh-ins they're
getting to doctors appointments we've
got a million different doctors tugging
and pulling on yeah then you're going
through all these meetings with these
teams and they grind you it seems like
the the meeting room has turned into
let's see if we can get under this guy's
again so when you're having to be on
defense now for three hours in the
evening and then you go to bed you got
to be up five and a half six hours later
to get out here and run yeah these guys
can get pretty exhausted if you had one
question to ask Baker Mayfield what
would it be
do you want to be a celebrity or do you
want to be a great quarterback mm-hmm
do you think he'll be honest then oh I
guarantee it I guarantee you talking
about pushing buttons they're gonna
they're gonna do that I mean I give you
an example of what that room can be like
then they'll the I guarantee you some
team went this route and said okay hey
Baker you know your size there's two
guys that have been really successful in
the NFL one is Russell Wilson and the
other one is Drew Brees and we've gone
back through all of our notes we don't
have any video or any notes on either
one of them running from the police and
we don't have any notes or any video of
them grabbing theirs you know what yes
on TV so how you know how committed are
you because those guys are psychopaths
when it comes to preparation work ethic
are you you putting yourself on that
same level they're gonna try and push
his buttons doing that guy stuff wait
you think that the question would be
phrased that way in that one-on-one
interview room oh no question no
question those guys okay they don't have
the ideal size so they've overcome that
with just a crazy work ethic their
characters off the charts but do you
think they would say you know in on that
these guys never ran from the police
Baker how do you answer Tate oh I get I
guarantee you they will say that have
you been in the room have you pushed
somebody's buttons when you were
scouting I'm a nice guy Danny I've seen
what's the
you say I've been in I've seen a guy sit
down a defensive lineman and shake
everybody's hand and sit down in the
room and the first question to him after
he's got a big smile on his face is why
do you play like such a coward Wow and
it was like and I'm like wow woah okay
here we go and I've been a player almost
trying to fight a coach so yeah that
stuff it gets interesting in there how
did the player react when he was called
a coward usually you know that's what
they want to see and he was upset and he
took it personally and I and I think
that's exactly what the coach wanted
from the player he wanted to see if it
bothered him and wrapped him know okay
alright son I pin you down there what
are the famous ones one of the famous
ones I remember which team but there was
a famous story about about Jared Allen
people you know what Coach kind of got
into him one after him pretty good and
then Jared Allen almost seemed across
the table took a swing Adam no boy all
right well play nice yeah he did play
nice today at the combine all right
Thank You Daniel that's a Daniel
Jeremiah NFL Network analyst you can
follow him on twitter at move the sticks
NFL Network providing exclusive live
coverage of the NFL Scouting Combine
today for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]